Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“迈向经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, we are looking at why you should apply for that research role. I am
这些原则都同样适用。还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天，我们将探讨为什么要申请研究类职位。我正在
talking to Jess, who works in a research capacity for the NHS, and she is guiding us through all her top tips and insight, wisdom and brilliance in the field of research. It's a really captivating lesson and one that you can't help but learn from and feel inspired by. I hope you find it so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, when I was an aspiring psychologist, I was looking at how to tick off my different areas of expertise. And one of the ones that felt a lot trickier for me to do was gaining research experience and feeling confident and capable of discussing
与Jess交谈，她在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）从事研究工作，她将为我们分享她在研究领域的所有顶级技巧、见解、智慧和才华。这是一堂非常引人入胜的课程，你一定会从中受益并受到启发。希望你觉得它很有用。欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。在我还是个有抱负的心理学家时，我一直在寻找如何达成我不同专业领域的方法。其中一个让我觉得比较棘手的是获得研究经验，并感到有信心和能力去讨论
research, handling research, dissecting research, planning research, all of that. And I came across a LinkedIn profile, which absolutely piqued my intrigue. And so I invited the profile owner onto the podcast so that we could learn more about her role. I think it is a fascinating episode. And I hope you will do too. Hope it inspires you to do whatever it is that you want to do from your psychology degree. That is what this podcast is all about. Please do like and fling a comment below as well if you're watching. I hope you'll find it useful and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi Jess, just want to welcome you along to the podcast. Thank you so much for joining us. Yeah, thank you
研究、处理研究、剖析研究、规划研究，所有这些。我偶然发现了一个LinkedIn个人资料，它完全激起了我的好奇心。于是我邀请了这位资料的主人来到播客，这样我们就能更多地了解她的角色。我认为这是一期非常精彩的节目，希望你也会这么觉得。希望它能激励你利用你的心理学学位去做任何你想做的事情。这就是本播客的宗旨。如果你正在观看，请点赞并在下方留言。希望你觉得它有用，我期待在节目之后与你交流。嗨，Jess，欢迎来到播客。非常感谢你加入我们。是的，谢谢
for having me. I appreciate it. Oh, absolutely my pleasure. So we got connected on LinkedIn, didn't we? And I was like, I've never met anyone with the title clinical research practitioner before. And that's how we thought it might be a useful podcast episode. But before we go into thinking about what your job is and what the role involves let's hear a little bit about you and what your journey has been in mental health so far. Yeah so it's kind of been up and down really I've been in quite a few different jobs I've done some volunteering so um obviously I've done uni I did my bachelor's and master's in forensic psychology um I knew I've always wanted to go in in mental health it was
邀请我。我很荣幸。哦，绝对是我的荣幸。我们是在LinkedIn上建立联系的，对吧？当时我就想，我从来没见过有人拥有“临床研究从业者”这个头衔。这就是我们认为这可能是一期有用的播客节目的原因。但在我们深入探讨你的工作内容和角色涉及的内容之前，让我们先听听关于你的一些情况，以及你迄今为止在心理健康领域的历程。是的，其实经历过起起伏伏，我做过很多不同的工作，也做过一些志愿者工作。嗯，显然我读了大学，获得了法医心理学的学士和硕士学位。我知道我一直想进入心理健康领域，这对我来说
just kind of the right pathway into it for me um I did volunteering with a company called community led initiatives I did that for quite a while whilst I was studying because I couldn't obviously have a full-time job and that was helping ex-offenders reintegrate back into the community and then after that I did some teaching assistant roles in different schools across Manchester and then I was a teaching assistant in an alternative provision of a high school and that was an interesting job to say the least it was a fantastic place to work and then now um obviously I'm doing the job that I'm doing now which is working in clinical research studies in mental health amazing you sound like you've had a very
是正确的途径。我在一家名为“社区主导倡议”（Community Led Initiatives）的公司做过很长一段时间的志愿者，当时我还在读书，因为我显然无法做全职工作。那份工作是帮助刑满释放人员重新融入社区。在那之后，我在曼彻斯特的几所学校担任过助教，后来又在一家高中的替代性教育机构担任助教。那份工作至少可以说很有趣，那是一个非常棒的工作场所。现在，嗯，显然我正在做我现在的工作，即在心理健康领域的临床研究中工作。太棒了，听起来你度过了非常
busy few years and drawing and developing on lots of different skills yeah it was it was one of them things I kind of didn't know what I wanted to go into with mental health so I thought if I kind of get as much experience as I can it'll help me inform where I want to go so I don't you know end up doing something for a couple years I'm not really that interested in and um yeah I just kind of wanted to do everything before I settled on what I you know actually wanted to do so it was good getting all that different type of experiences. Amazing and did you just sort of decide now's the time to do something a bit different or was the opportunity kind of offered to you? How did your current role come about? Yeah the job that I'm doing now it's a bit crazy when I think about how I actually got into
忙碌的几年，并且在很多不同的技能上得到了锻炼和发展。是的，确实是这样。我当时不太确定自己想在心理健康领域从事什么，所以我想如果我能尽可能多地获得经验，这将有助于我确定我想去的地方，这样我就不会在几年后做一些我并不真正感兴趣的事情。嗯，是的，我只是想在决定自己真正想做什么之前尝试一切，所以获得所有这些不同类型的经验是很好的。太棒了，你是突然决定现在是时候做点不同的事情了，还是机会主动找上你的？你目前的工作是怎么来的？是的，我现在做的工作，当我想到我是如何进入
it so I never thought of going into research I didn't even realize it was a a job role I know it sounds a bit crazy but you don't really think do you that research is a viable route for you to go into especially at like an entry level um and I just in my old job I knew it was kind of time to move on I'd got the experience that I wanted from that um and so I was just looking around applying for a few different jobs that job role came up and I think it was a couple months I want to say two months after something like that and they said do you want an interview and by that time I'm scratching my head thinking yes I can't really remember what it's for but absolutely I would like an interview
这个领域时，觉得有点疯狂。我从来没想过要从事研究工作，我甚至没意识到这是一个职位。我知道这听起来有点疯狂，但你真的不会想到研究是你进入的一个可行途径，尤其是在入门级。嗯，在我的旧工作中，我知道是时候离开了，我已经获得了我想要的经验。所以我只是四处看看，申请了几份不同的工作。那个职位出现了，我想大概是两个月后，或者类似的时间，他们问我是否想要面试。到那时，我挠着头想，是的，我不记得是为什么申请的，但绝对，我想要面试。
and yeah obviously applied for it did the interview I really didn't think I was going to get the job so I kind of just went into it thinking you know just be myself and you know if I get the job fantastic if I don't I kind of already had the expectation that I might not get it so yes I feel very lucky that I've been the expectation that I might not get it so yeah it's I feel very lucky that I've been able to get this job and get the experience in research and meet all the different people that I've met because you know a lot of the people that I speak to say that research is one of the hardest places to get experience other than when you do your education in uni so yeah I'm very very grateful to be in the role that I'm in now.
是的，显然申请了，也参加了面试。我真的没想过我会得到这份工作，所以我只是抱着“做我自己”的心态去参加，你知道，如果我得到了这份工作，那太棒了；如果没得到，我也已经有了可能不会被录用的心理准备。所以，是的，我觉得自己非常幸运能够得到这份工作，获得研究经验，并结识我所遇到的所有不同的人。因为你知道，我交谈过的很多人都说，除了在大学接受教育之外，研究是获得经验最难的地方之一。所以，是的，我非常非常感激能处于我现在这个职位。
Yeah it really is and I was reflecting upon that as you spoke really that often when people come to me as part of the membership or even with questions about kind of professional roots in psychology it's the research that feels like it's a bit of an Achilles heel that it feels like they need developing and if you're not working in a trust that seems to do much research or your supervisor's not involved in research or you haven't done a master's it can definitely feel like it's a diff a more difficult competence to kind of thicken your thicken your experience in yeah i completely agree um especially for people that want to go into the d clean and things things like that I genuinely didn't realise how valuable the work that I'm doing now is for the rest of my
是的，确实如此。当你说话时，我真的在反思这一点。通常当人们作为会员的一部分来找我，或者带着关于心理学职业道路的问题来找我时，研究往往感觉像是他们的“阿喀琉斯之踵”（弱点），他们觉得需要加强。如果你工作的信托机构似乎不做太多研究，或者你的导师不参与研究，或者你没有读过硕士，这肯定会让人觉得是一个更难积累经验的领域。是的，我完全同意。嗯，特别是对于那些想进入临床心理学博士课程（DClin）的人来说。我真的没意识到我现在所做的工作对于我的
you know my career really so yeah it's definitely a fantastic place to get into if you can and if there's jobs available out there but it's just knowing where to look as well isn't it so yeah I definitely would would say that if you can get in in this way um then do so but with the job that I do the ACRP so um that is it's quite a new role um it kind of works in conjunction with a research assistant so um I think I'm getting ahead of myself here with a question later on down the line but but I'll carry on anyway. Yeah, so I help recruit into clinical studies and get them through the consent process, do the baseline measures, which is a few different questionnaires to measure what we want at the beginning of the study.
职业生涯来说有多么宝贵。所以，是的，如果可以的话，这绝对是一个进入的好地方，如果有工作机会的话。但关键在于知道去哪里寻找，不是吗？所以，是的，我绝对会说，如果你能以这种方式进入，那就去做吧。但我所做的ACRP工作，嗯，那是一个相当新的角色。它有点像与研究助理协同工作。嗯，我想我在这里有点超前了，后面会有相关的问题，但我还是继续说吧。是的，所以我帮助招募参与者进入临床研究，引导他们完成知情同意过程，进行基线测量，也就是在研究开始时进行一些不同的问卷调查，以衡量我们想要研究的内容。
So we can compare at a later date, you know, to see how effective the treatment might have been or it might not have been. And the research assistant then does like the follow-ups and things like that um but yeah so I completely forgot what my point was but that's what I do. Okay so are you sort of supporting with what we learn about in research as being the gold standard of research which is randomized controls trials are you sort of doing all of that you know assigning people and getting them through the onboarding processes for that yep doing all the good stuff um so I liaise with like clinical services whichever one is you know deemed suitable for the research that we're currently working on um kind of integrate myself within that team I screen off their waiting list or through like referrals and then get people in I'm at the first point of contact with potential participants
这样我们可以在以后的日期进行比较，你知道，看看治疗效果如何，或者可能效果并不明显。然后研究助理会做后续跟进之类的工作。嗯，是的，我完全忘了我要说什么了，但这就是我的工作。好的，那么你是在支持我们所了解的研究中的“黄金标准”，即随机对照试验吗？你是在做所有这些工作，你知道，分配人员并引导他们完成入职流程吗？是的，做所有这些好事。所以，我与临床服务部门联络，无论哪个部门被认为适合我们目前正在进行的研究，我都会把自己融入到那个团队中。我筛选他们的候补名单或通过转诊，然后把人招进来。我是潜在参与者的第一个联系点，
then explain what the study is take them through the consent process obviously make sure they've had a amount of time away so they can have a think about if they want to take part and then yeah we do the consent and we will start on the baseline measures which again is i said it's just like a few different questionnaires to measure how they might be feeling so then we can compare at a later date um but as part of my job role i also have an additional um additional job role to this which is a study facilitator um and that basically means that I upload the recruitment data onto the system the CPMS system and then that directly affects the
然后解释研究内容，引导他们完成知情同意过程。显然，要确保他们有足够的时间去考虑是否要参加。然后，是的，我们进行知情同意，并开始基线测量，正如我所说的，这只是几个不同的问卷，用来衡量他们的感受，以便我们以后可以进行比较。嗯，但作为我工作的一部分，我还有一个额外的职位，即研究促进者（Study Facilitator）。这基本上意味着我将招募数据上传到系统，即CPMS系统，这直接影响到
funding that the study gets based on how many participants are put onto this database and that kind of job role comes with a whole other like little additional tasks which is liaising with the research office um making sure that the principal investigator who runs the study is aware of any like um updates on amendments that they might have put in and things like that so um it's it's a lot of responsibility but when you actually get into it like for me now when I first started it really overwhelmed me I thought you know am I capable of working at this level am I capable interacting with all these like you know top researchers and things like that but now that I'm in it it just it feels like second nature um so yeah I think it's definitely it seems to to me and you know probably to other
研究获得的资金，取决于有多少参与者被录入这个数据库。那个职位还伴随着一大堆其他的小任务，比如与研究办公室联络，确保负责研究的首席研究员了解他们可能提交的任何修订更新等等。所以，嗯，这责任很大，但当你真正进入状态时，就像我现在这样，刚开始时我真的感到不知所措。我想，你知道，我有能力在这个水平上工作吗？我有能力与所有这些顶尖研究人员互动吗？但现在我身处其中，这感觉就像第二天性。所以，是的，我认为这绝对是……对我来说，可能对其他人来说，
people that it's an intimidating job to go into but once you're in there and you kind of know how everything operates it's it's yeah it's just fantastic I I feel like I'm biased I have to big up my job role but truly it is a fantastic place to get into and to work for yeah it sounds amazing and I think what you're evidencing really nicely is you know when we do a role we just begin to become skilled at it and the things that might have sounded daunting like some of the phrases you were kind of punting out there like you know lead investigator and you know oh man but it just becomes commonplace to you whereas I remember when I kind of filled in my ethics forms for my doctorate research and you have to kind of call yourself the principal
这是一个令人望而生畏的工作，但一旦你进入其中，了解了一切是如何运作的，它就……是的，这太棒了。我觉得我有偏见，我必须夸奖我的职位，但它确实是一个进入和工作的好地方。是的，听起来太棒了。我认为你证明得非常好的是，你知道，当我们担任一个角色时，我们就会开始变得熟练。那些听起来令人生畏的事情，比如你提到的一些短语，像“首席研究员”之类的，哦天哪，但这对你来说变得司空见惯了。而我记得当我为我的博士研究填写伦理表格时，你必须称自己为“首席研究员”，当时我就想，我觉得自己像个骗子。我所看到的是，你所谈论的一切和你所经历的一切，确实为你未来所做的一切打下了很好的基础，即使是你自己未来的研究。但对于未来，你可能在临床服务部门工作，那时客户不确定是否应该参与研究，你可以与他们进行非常有帮助、知情的讨论，来探讨这会涉及什么。
investigator like oh I feel fraudulent like what I see is everything you're talking about and everything you're experiencing it really does you know set you up really well for anything you do in future even if it's your own research in future um but for helping you know in future you may be working in clinical services where a client's not sure about whether they should or shouldn't get involved in research and you can have a really helpful informed discussion with them to kind of discuss what that would involve yeah yeah and I mean it helps it helps as well being able to um be like embedded in some of the clinical teams so I've worked um within early intervention within this job role I've worked in the prison system
是的，是的。而且能够嵌入到一些临床团队中也有帮助。所以我在这个职位上曾在早期干预部门工作过，在监狱系统工作过，
um I've worked in CAMHS I've worked in IAP services so not only do you get kind of a roundabout view of the services that you work in and how mental health services work in general but you also get to meet all these different people all these different practitioners and you're able to kind of bridge the gap between research and you know the people that are actually dealing with mental health as like the the I can't think of the the right phrase in like the first responders you know the people that are actually embedded in in helping the service users with you know whatever they might be be facing um because a lot of people i think they kind of don't really know much about research
在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作过，在心理治疗服务（IAP）工作过。所以你不仅能全面了解你所工作的服务部门以及心理健康服务是如何运作的，而且你还能结识所有这些不同的人、所有这些不同的从业者。你能够弥合研究与那些真正处理心理健康问题的人之间的差距，就像……我想不出合适的词，就像“急救人员”，你知道，那些真正嵌入在帮助服务使用者面对他们可能面临的任何问题的人。因为很多人，我认为他们对研究了解不多，
or sometimes might not see the benefit of it um and it's nice being able to bridge the gap in between them both um so yeah yeah it sounds amazing i guess what i hadn't realized is just how many clinical populations you're being able to work with because of the changing nature of your research studies it sounds incredible and in terms of you know i'm often thinking about when people are getting feedback about their professional psychology applications you know and in the old days you used to get like you know more varied clinical experience more research experience needed you know more clinical experience needed like you're you're just like you're just ticking off all of those competencies you know so. There's less and less reasons why somebody would say, oh, not ready for this next stage of what you want.
或者有时可能看不到它的好处。能够弥合两者之间的差距真是太好了。所以，是的。是的，听起来太棒了。我想我没意识到的是，由于你的研究课题的不断变化，你能够接触到这么多不同的临床人群。这听起来令人难以置信。就……你知道，我经常想到当人们在获得关于他们的专业心理学申请的反馈时，你知道，在过去，你通常会得到像“需要更多样化的临床经验，需要研究经验，需要更多临床经验”这样的反馈。就像你……你只是在勾选所有这些能力，你知道。所以，几乎没有理由说某人“还没准备好迎接你想要的下一阶段”。
But of course, you may choose to just stay where you are right now and work in research and become a principal researcher yourself. You know, it's not necessarily that it's always going to be, you know, a throughput job to then go on and do professional psychology but what you've evidenced beautifully is that once you've done a psychology degree it can take you in such a beautiful variety of directions yeah and i really think that the biggest piece of advice that i can give anybody that's on the same journey that i've been on is that even if you think you might not be eligible you don't meet the requirements for a job just go for it and truly don't stress about trying to get all the answers and give these you know textbook responses they just really want you to be yourself because if if you're interested in this type of work and you've got some kind of
但当然，你可能选择留在现在的位置，从事研究工作，并自己成为一名首席研究员。你知道，这并不一定意味着它总是会成为通往专业心理学的跳板，但你已经完美地证明了，一旦你获得了心理学学位，它可以带你走向如此多样化的美好方向。是的，我真的认为我能给任何处于我所经历的同样旅程中的人最大的建议是，即使你认为自己可能没有资格，你不符合工作的要求，也要去尝试。真的不要为了试图得到所有答案和给出这些教科书式的回答而感到压力。他们只是真的想让你做你自己。因为如果你对这类工作感兴趣，并且你有一些
relevant experience then go for it because you'd honestly be so shocked at the opportunities that you miss out through kind of thinking that you might not be ready you might not be good enough um and you know this is why when everybody asked me how I got into this role I like to kind of put in there that I didn't think I was going to get this job I didn't think that I would meet the requirements I thought it'd be too difficult for me especially because I'd never worked in research before and now that I'm in it like you said it's just fantastic the amount of different experiences I'm getting all within the same role my day-to-day is completely different all the time I've interacted with so many different people
相关的经验，那就去尝试吧。因为你真的会因为认为自己可能还没准备好、可能不够好而错失机会，这会让你感到非常震惊。嗯，你知道，这就是为什么当每个人问我我是如何进入这个职位的，我喜欢提到我当时没想过我会得到这份工作。我不认为我会满足要求，我认为这对我来说太难了，特别是因为我以前从未从事过研究工作。而现在我身处其中，就像你说的，这太棒了，我在同一个职位上获得了如此多的不同经验。我的日常工作总是完全不同。我与这么多不同的人互动，
professionals and different service users I've heard so many different stories um I've had to deal with like varying situations risk situations and I don't I think there's there's nothing more valuable than hands-on experience especially when you're working in these types of environments with the right support and obviously within research it's very, I mean, in most services it is. But especially within research, you've got to make sure you have like clinical cover. You've got to make sure that you've got people around you constantly to be able to say, have I dealt with this risk situation correctly? Should I have done this differently? You know, I said this to a participant that didn't particularly react very well like could I improve on this and um yeah it's it's definitely something
专业人士和不同的服务使用者。我听过这么多不同的故事。我不得不处理各种情况，风险情况。而且我不认为有什么比实践经验更有价值的，特别是在这些类型的环境中，有正确的支持。显然在研究中，我的意思是，在大多数服务中都是这样。但特别是在研究中，你必须确保你有临床保障。你必须确保你身边一直有人，能够让你问：“我处理这种风险情况正确吗？我应该换种方式做吗？你知道，我对参与者说了这句话，他们的反应不太好，我能改进吗？”所以，是的，这绝对是……
like like I keep saying um go into it if you can amazing thanks Jess that's so interesting and um I've got so many things I want to say to you next but it made it made me think about some research um I'd become aware of about gender and employability and the employment processes and something that was like um men are more likely to apply for jobs that they don't have all the clinical yes or they don't have all the essential personal criteria for in terms of the person spec but women are more likely to only apply if they're like 90 95 percent meeting the criteria and so that in that way you're more likely to get men in higher jobs because there's going to be more more men applying for those higher jobs exactly i as soon as you said that it made me think about i also saw a piece of research I don't know if it was the same one but it was about um pay rises and it said that men um often get pay rises more so
就像我一直说的，如果可以的话，就去尝试吧。太棒了，谢谢Jess，这太有趣了。嗯，我还有很多话想对你说，但这让我想起了一些关于性别和就业能力以及就业过程的研究。有些研究说，男性更有可能申请他们并不具备所有临床……或者他们并不具备所有基本个人标准的职位，就个人规格而言。而女性更有可能只有在满足90%到95%的标准时才申请。所以，从这个意义上说，你更有可能让男性进入更高的职位，因为会有更多的男性申请那些更高的职位。完全正确。你一说这个，就让我想起我也看过一项研究，我不确定是不是同一项，但它是关于加薪的。它说男性通常比女性更容易获得加薪，
than women do because they ask for them and it really it struck a chord because I thought you know there's so many women out there that are missing out on these extremely fantastic opportunities because of things like that um and you know especially within mental health um not to say that men don't have an empathic side because they do but you know women they're just more in tuned that way and I think that just having that compassion and empathy would get you a lot farther in the the job process than you might think so um yeah if you don't meet all the the specification still absolutely go for it the worst they can say is no so you know absolutely I'm a massive advocate for go for it you've got nothing to lose oh I love that I love
因为他们会主动要求。这真的引起了共鸣，因为我想，你知道，有这么多女性因为这样的事情而错失了这些极其棒的机会。而且，你知道，特别是在心理健康领域，并不是说男性没有同理心，因为他们有，但你知道，女性在这一方面更敏锐。我认为拥有那种同情心和同理心会让你在求职过程中比你想象的走得更远。所以，是的，如果你不满足所有的规格，仍然绝对要去尝试。他们最坏的结果就是说“不”。所以，你知道，绝对的，我是“去尝试”的坚定拥护者，你没什么可失去的。哦，我喜欢这个，我喜欢
that and you know I'm thinking well okay so if I for this job, I don't quite meet the spec for what is an interview going to be like for a research practitioner? They are going to rip me to shreds. They're going to ask me all sorts of difficult research questions. You know, what what was that process like for you? The interview process. So beforehand, I'd really built up in my own head um exactly what you said I thought it was going to be really tough I thought it was going to grill me on absolutely everything um it wasn't like that at all um I did a 10 minute presentation um I can't exactly remember what the question was but it was in a sense why is research important what value does it have um for the community and you know the wider um population so I did like a very brief
这个。而且我在想，好吧，如果我申请这份工作，我不完全符合规格，研究从业者的面试会是什么样的？他们会把我撕成碎片吗？他们会问我各种各样的困难研究问题吗？你知道，那个过程对你来说是什么样的？面试过程。所以事先，我在脑海中真的建立了很多……正如你所说的，我认为这会非常艰难，我认为他们会对我进行全方位的盘问。根本不是那样。我做了一个10分钟的演讲。我不记得确切的问题是什么了，但从某种意义上说，它是“为什么研究很重要？它对社区和更广泛的人群有什么价值？”所以我做了一个非常简短的
presentation on that and put a lot of research citations in there just to kind of show my knowledge um and then after that it was a question and answer but it was like it was obviously knowledge-based questions like you know if this happened how would you deal with this but it was very relaxed the people that I had on the panel I've worked with since getting the job and they were just themselves they were exactly the type of person that I've got to know them as after I you know got the role um so it was very relaxed very chilled out um because I was kind of my mind was running a mile a minute I had to keep asking them to repeat the question um and I really thought that would like go against me because I thought oh they're not they're gonna think that
演讲，并在其中放入了很多研究引用，只是为了展示我的知识。然后在那之后是问答环节，但那是基于知识的问题，比如“如果发生了这种情况，你会怎么处理？”但它非常放松。我在面试小组中见到的人，我在得到这份工作后与他们共事过，他们就是他们自己。他们正是那种我在得到职位后所了解到的那种人。所以，面试非常放松，非常冷静。因为我的大脑当时转得飞快，我不得不一直要求他们重复问题。我真的以为这会对我产生不利影响，因为我想，哦，他们会认为
I'm not listening or I'm not you know involved or anything like that but um yeah I was just myself because they kind of fostered this environment where I could be comfortable and that really helped me get the job but yeah so the the actual process itself um wasn't as daunting as I thought it was going to be I just built it up in my own head. It sounds like they um they were screening you for your soft skills and your kind of personability as much as as much as what you knew because obviously they know what sort of roles you're going to be in are you ever working people's homes or is it always in clinical settings no so I can work in people's homes but
我没在听，或者我没参与，或者类似的事情。但，是的，我只是做我自己，因为他们营造了这种让我感到舒适的环境，这真的帮助我得到了这份工作。但，是的，实际的过程本身并没有我想象的那么令人生畏。我只是在脑海中把它想得太严重了。听起来他们是在筛选你的软技能和你的亲和力，和你所知道的一样多。因为显然他们知道你将要担任什么样的角色。你会在人们的家中工作吗，还是总是在临床环境中？不，我可以在人们的家中工作，但
it's just kind of discretion based personally I try not to do that. But if, you know, for example, if some people need that for whatever reason, they have mobility issues, they have kind of something that gives them a bit more anxiety about going out of the house, I will do that. But because I'm not clinically trained and because, you know, I'm kind of when I was new to the role, I was a bit more anxious about that but now um I'd feel a lot more comfortable doing it but it's mostly um mostly in the clinical services but we can I would I would say that you do have loads of clinical skills and training yeah um and all the stuff you said before about all the stuff you're working with, kind of young offenders and stuff like that, like that is definitely teaching you clinical skills. And yeah, you may not be you may not be yet professionally qualified, but I would say that you definitely have clinical skills. But this is the thing, and it's about trusting yourself, trusting your own judgment and the person ability and things like that I think it's took me
这取决于具体情况。就我个人而言，我尽量不那样做。但如果，你知道，例如，如果有些人因为某种原因需要那样，他们有行动不便的问题，他们对走出家门感到有点焦虑，我会那样做。但因为我没有受过临床培训，而且因为，你知道，当我刚入职时，我对那件事感到有点焦虑，但现在，嗯，我会觉得做起来舒服多了。但它大多是在临床服务部门。但我会说，你确实有很多临床技能和培训。是的，而且你之前说的所有关于你正在处理的事情，比如年轻罪犯之类的事情，那绝对是在教你临床技能。是的，你可能还不是专业合格的，但我会说你绝对拥有临床技能。但这正是关键所在，关于信任自己，信任你自己的判断力和亲和力等等。我认为这花了我
a long time in this job to kind of feel comfortable with that I am competent um it's kind of like remnants of you know feeling like imposter syndrome where I don't really well I do now but I didn't really trust that oh have I done this right have I done this right but with the um the experiences that I've had and the positions that I've like kind of been put in the environment um yeah it kind of forces you to know that you you're good at what you do you know what you're doing so um yeah it's just about learning to trust yourself as well I think that's one of the most difficult parts of the the journey into psychology like you know what you're doing so kind of give yourself more credit yeah for sure and even myself you know I've been qualified since 2011 you know and I still have that oh you're gonna be rambled you know and even when I'm doing this podcast I think oh people are gonna be like
很长时间才在这个工作中感到舒适，即我是胜任的。这有点像“冒名顶替综合症”的残留，我不确定……好吧，我现在确定了，但我当时并不真正相信，“哦，我做对了吗？我做对了吗？”但通过我所拥有的经验和被置于其中的环境，是的，它迫使你知道你擅长你所做的事情，你知道你在做什么。所以，是的，这只是关于学会信任自己。我认为这是进入心理学旅程中最困难的部分之一，你知道你在做什么，所以给自己多一点肯定。是的，当然。即使是我自己，你知道，我从2011年就合格了，你知道，我仍然会有那种“哦，你会搞砸的”的感觉。即使我在做这个播客时，我也想，哦，人们会觉得
oh Marianne's clinical skills there were a bit off. But, you know, as long as you do it with a good heart and you're not actively setting out to be, you know, putting someone at risk. Like I think, you know, and I think you need to be aware of everything you don't yet know. But, you know, it's feeling comfortable with the things that, you know, you're doing well enough, I think. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I agree completely agree yeah and we can always learn something from observing our colleagues or our supervisors do something you know that's a really nice a really nice thing but we don't necessarily need to be daunted by that we could think about that as a learning opportunity yeah I mean yeah we do a lot of shadowing um in the in the services that I work in and that is where I kind of learn most of the skills that I have now kind of see how they would
“哦，Marianne的临床技能有点欠缺。”但是，你知道，只要你怀着一颗善良的心去做，并且不是故意要让某人处于危险之中。就像我认为，你需要意识到你还不知道的一切。但是，你知道，对你做得足够好的事情感到舒适，我认为是这样。是的，是的，是的，我同意，完全同意。是的，我们可以通过观察我们的同事或导师做某事来学习一些东西，你知道，那是一件非常好的事情。但我们不一定需要被此吓倒，我们可以把它看作是一个学习机会。是的，我的意思是，是的，我们做了很多影子工作（观察学习），在我工作的服务部门中，这就是我学习我现在拥有的大部分技能的地方。观察他们如何
react how would they deal with certain situations um and then obviously having somebody shadow me when I kind of then was on the journey to loan working but yeah they were that was probably one of the best learning experiences for me. Great and are they I'm assuming the NHS roles what sort of banding are the roles coming out at if that doesn't feel like too too improper a question to ask you that's absolutely fine i'm all for band and pay transparency um so what i'm working at is a band four um and a research assistant which is you know they they're what kind of what i touched on before they do like the follow-ups and things like that um they are mostly band four as well but some of them can be at band five um but yeah mine's at a band four.
反应，他们如何处理某些情况。然后显然当我在独立工作的旅程中，有人观察我。但，是的，那可能是我最好的学习经历之一。太棒了，他们是……我假设是NHS的角色，如果问这个问题不太冒昧的话，这些角色的薪资等级是多少？这绝对没问题，我完全支持薪资透明度。所以我现在工作的是四级（Band 4）。研究助理，也就是你之前提到的，他们做后续跟进之类的工作，他们大多也是四级，但有些人可以是五级。但，是的，我的是四级。
Thank thank you I know that that will be a question that people are wondering so it's kind of yeah like I was I only ever made it to band four assistant psychologist um so it's kind of yeah similar kind of pay levels well the same yeah same pay levels yeah and is it only ever one research study at a time or were you constantly juggling different ones no absolutely not so I think at one time I was working on about five um at the moment I'm working on three um and they kind of they have um quarterly reviews of ACRP allocation so um they'll kind of say well this research unit needs two days of your time this research unit needs three days of your time and then they'll divvy it up between themselves so
谢谢，我知道这会是人们想知道的问题。所以，这有点像……我曾经只达到四级助理心理学家，所以这有点像……类似的薪资水平。是的，同样的薪资水平。而且是一次只做一个研究项目，还是你一直在同时处理不同的项目？不，绝对不是。所以我认为有一次我同时在做大约五个。目前我正在做三个。他们有ACRP分配的季度审查。所以他们会说，“这个研究单位需要你两天的时间，这个研究单位需要你三天的时间”，然后他们会在他们之间分配。
um under one research unit for two days you could be working one day on one study one day on another study and then for the three days remaining you could work two days on one study and then the remaining day on another study um so it really just depends on your um time allocations to each study what study study needs are, and obviously how comfortable you are with the amount of work you're doing, and kind of managing your own time, but they're quite good with kind of keeping in constant contact through supervision, to see how you're getting on with things, is it too much, can you take on a little bit more um so yeah currently I'm working on three studies one of them is due to end in February so we're having talks at the minute about other studies that are coming
所以，在一个研究单位工作两天，你可能一天做一个研究，一天做另一个研究。然后剩下的三天，你可能两天做一个研究，剩下的一天做另一个研究。所以这真的取决于你对每个研究的时间分配，研究的需求，以及你对所做工作量的适应程度，以及管理你自己的时间。但他们非常擅长通过督导保持持续联系，看看你做得怎么样，是不是太多了，能不能再多承担一点。所以，是的，目前我正在做三个研究。其中一个预计在二月结束，所以我们现在正在讨论其他即将到来的研究，
up that I can like become involved with brilliant thank you and are they are we what we're looking at like medication studies or therapy studies or does it really depend like all of these things and above and beyond and difference like what are we looking at? There is about eight research units but I only work with the non-medication trials I can't think of what the correct term is but mine's all intervention or therapy based so um I'm currently working on one called prospect which is um working within the prison system and that is looking at suicide prevention in prisons for men um I also work on something called relate which is um trialing cognitive analytical therapy for self-harm in step three IAP services and above
我可以参与其中。太棒了，谢谢。我们是在看药物研究还是治疗研究，还是真的取决于……所有这些以及更多？我们在看什么？大约有八个研究单位，但我只与非药物试验合作。我想不出正确的术语，但我的是基于干预或治疗的。所以，我目前正在做一个名为“Prospect”的项目，它是在监狱系统中工作的，旨在研究男性监狱中的自杀预防。我还参与了一个名为“Relate”的项目，它是在三级IAP服务及以上级别中，为自残行为试行认知分析疗法。
and then the final one I work on is called BAE which is working in CAM services so that that's like quite a big trial it's kind of all over the country um looking at behavioral activation in youths I love that they've called it BAE because like youths are all about their BAEs but like actually it's kind of behavioral activation that's why they've called it bay because like youths are all about their bays but like actually it's kind of behavioral activation that's why they've called it bay is that right every yeah every time that I say that to people they give me like a bit of a side eye and they're like bay as in like like like bay like boyfriend girlfriend I'm like no no no no no I don't mean that amazing so not every trust will have a research unit it's is it sort of localized I do think most trusts do have their own research unit yeah um okay it just depends
最后一个我参与的项目叫“BAE”，是在CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）中工作的。那是一个相当大的试验，它遍布全国，研究青少年的行为激活（Behavioral Activation）。我喜欢他们把它称为“BAE”，因为年轻人总是谈论他们的“BAE”（宝贝/对象），但实际上它是“行为激活”。这就是为什么他们称之为“BAE”。是这样吗？是的，每次我告诉人们这一点时，他们都会给我一个侧目，他们会说：“BAE？就像男朋友/女朋友？”我说：“不，不，不，不，我不是那个意思。”太棒了。所以并不是每个信托机构都有研究单位，它是本地化的吗？我确实认为大多数信托机构都有自己的研究单位，是的。好的，这只是取决于
like how big it is and whether they liaise with like different trusts so for example um on bay they it's run by gmmh so under research and innovation but we work with pennine we work with um yorkshire research innovation um and kind of all over so it's kind of a joint a joint effort i suppose perfect thank you is there anything i haven't asked you that you think would be useful for our listeners and our watchers to know or understand about your role? Yeah I think one of the biggest things about this job role it really is about time management and especially saying no if you can do something so I know at first I kind of really struggled with uh saying no I don't know how to do this um no I can't give you any more of my time I
它有多大，以及他们是否与不同的信托机构联络。例如，在“BAE”项目中，它由GMMH（大曼彻斯特心理健康NHS基金会信托）运营，在研究与创新部门下，但我们与Pennine合作，我们与Yorkshire Research Innovation合作，以及全国各地。所以这是一种联合努力，我想。太完美了，谢谢。还有什么我没问你的，你认为对我们的听众和观众来说，了解你的角色是有用的吗？是的，我认为这个职位最重要的事情之一确实是时间管理，特别是如果可以的话，学会说“不”。我知道起初我真的很难说“不，我不知道怎么做这个”或者“不，我不能再给你更多时间了，我
you know I don't have any time to give you so it's about kind of yeah just kind of sticking up for yourself um some people might not struggle with that but I know I did um it's got to the point now where they're like oh can you take on a little bit more and I'm like no no I've got too many things to be doing I'm busy enough as it is um but yeah I think that's that's um one of the biggest time management definitely something to to be aware of that's really empowering and actually I often ask people at the end of podcast episodes what's your tip for reducing burnout as a in a in mental health and aspiring psychologists I think that's it you know you're allowed to say no or if someone says well this is really important this needs doing you're kind of looking at well I can't do all of this so could you help me look at my priorities to work out
没有时间给你”。所以这关于……是的，只是为自己挺身而出。有些人可能不会为此挣扎，但我知道我挣扎过。现在已经到了他们说“哦，你能再多承担一点吗？”而我说“不，不，我有太多事情要做，我已经够忙了”的地步。但，是的，我认为那是……时间管理绝对是需要注意的事情。这真的很有力量。事实上，我经常在播客结束时问人们：“作为心理健康领域的有抱负的心理学家，你减少职业倦怠的秘诀是什么？”我认为就是这样，你知道，你被允许说“不”。或者如果有人说“这真的很重要，这需要做”，你是在看“好吧，我不能做所有这些，所以你能帮我看看我的优先级，以确定
which which other one I can put down because I can't do all of this there's only one of me yeah exactly and I think it's also taking advantage of the support that's within your job itself um because obviously within mental health you get your own kind of internal hub that will will help you out with whatever you might be uh you know you might be needing I think it's just kind of trying to reduce the stigma around well you know I might not have it as bad as the people that I'm working with so I have nothing to worry about or I have nothing to complain about because I know I've experienced that before you're hearing a lot about all these really traumatic things that people experienced and then when you kind of you can look at your own life and it pales in comparison
我可以放下哪一个吗？因为我不能做所有这些，我只有一个人。”是的，完全正确。而且我认为这也包括利用你工作本身内部的支持。因为显然在心理健康领域，你有你自己的内部中心，会帮助你解决你可能需要的任何事情。我认为这只是试图减少围绕“好吧，你知道，我可能不像我正在帮助的人那样糟糕，所以我没什么可担心的，或者我没什么可抱怨的”的污名。因为我知道我以前经历过，你听到了很多关于人们经历的这些非常创伤的事情，然后当你审视自己的生活时，它就显得微不足道了。
and you think well you know mine the way I'm feeling I'm burnt out from work it's not as bad but you know it you need to look after yourself to be able to then look after the people that you're working with so you know manage your time well make sure that you can say no to people when it's you know when it's needed and access the support that people are offering you and that you job and the trust itself can give you because I just think it's so important it really is and it's good to know that you still get supervision around that because it can be so containing especially when you're trying to learn about an area yeah and of course what we know is that supervision you know its primary function is is client protection and safety and that's incredibly important in the role that you're doing yeah definitely I agree I get supervision um every
你会想，你知道，我现在的感觉是工作倦怠，情况还没那么糟，但你需要照顾好自己，才能照顾好与你共事的人。所以，你要善于管理时间，在必要时学会拒绝他人，并利用好别人提供给你的支持，以及你的工作和信托机构本身能给予你的支持。我认为这非常重要，真的。很高兴知道你在这方面还能得到督导，因为这非常有包容性，尤其是在你试图学习一个新领域的时候。是的，当然，我们知道督导的主要功能是保护客户和确保安全，这在你所从事的角色中极其重要。
week so it's you know it's fantastic for me I'm able to get the support I need on such a consistent and regular basis and it's why it's been it's not been easy but it's been much more manageable um to kind of ease into the job manage my own time loan work and all that kind of stuff um it's really helped me settle into it like quite well good it's been an absolute pleasure speaking with you and thank you so much for helping illuminate our audience about about research and how it doesn't need to be scary and how you absolutely can and should apply for those research jobs yes definitely please do and yeah thank you for having me it's been brilliant being on being on here oh you're so welcome thank you so
每周一次，这对我来说太棒了。我能够以如此持续和规律的方式获得我需要的支持，这就是为什么虽然不容易，但适应这份工作、管理自己的时间、独立工作等等，都变得更加可控了。这真的帮助我很好地适应了这份工作。很好，和你交谈真是太愉快了。非常感谢你帮助我们的听众了解研究，告诉他们研究并不需要令人恐惧，以及他们绝对可以也应该去申请那些研究工作。是的，一定要去申请。谢谢你邀请我，能来到这里真是太棒了。不客气，非常感谢你。
much for your time jess yeah no worries thank you how incredible. And just after I stopped record on that episode with Jess, I said that I hadn't wanted to ask her publicly what her career plans were in case she upset her employees. But she said, I'd been all right with that. So she said that originally she wanted to do forensic psychology. Actually, now she's really considering clinical psychology and she feels like she's building good skills and experiences there. So, you know, I love how versatile a psychology degree can be. And I know Jessie's was a forensic psychology degree, she said at the beginning. But, you know, it can take us in so many different glorious directions.
抽出时间来，杰斯。不用客气，谢谢。真是太不可思议了。就在我结束与杰斯的录音后，我说我本来不想公开问她职业规划是什么，以免惹恼她的雇主。但她说，她没关系。她说她最初想从事法医心理学。实际上，现在她正在认真考虑临床心理学，她觉得自己在那里积累了很好的技能和经验。所以，你知道，我喜欢心理学学位所具备的多样性。我知道杰西在开头说过她的是法医心理学学位，但你知道，它可以引领我们走向许多不同而辉煌的方向。
So whatever stage of your career you are at, as you listen to this or watch this thank you for spending the time with me thank you for trusting me to help you learn more about this really important area if you'd like me to help further your knowledge and expertise even more do please consider coming along and joining the aspiring psychologist membership which you can do from just 30 pounds a month do also check out the aspiring psychologist collective Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. And I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the podcast, which will be along for you from 6am on Monday. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
所以，无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，当你收听或观看本期节目时，感谢你花时间陪伴我，感谢你信任我，让我帮助你更多地了解这个非常重要的领域。如果你希望我进一步帮助你提升知识和专业水平，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，每月仅需30英镑。也请查看《有抱负的心理学家集体》一书和《临床心理学家集体》一书。我期待在下一期播客中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。让本播客成为你的指南，有它在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是玛丽安博士的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现书中关于人们如何成为临床心理学家的不同故事非常有趣。各种通往成功的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有所谓的完美路径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。